[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
and welcome to cooking with
last episode we did swedish pancakes
although thanks to a hundred thousand
comments apparently
they're not swedish pancakes so today
we're making something actually swedish
okay guaranteedly swedish
house vision put it up
there side
and then explosion this is the most
swedish
as it gets housed
visual attacks oh as you guys know
i'm a bit of an expert because i used to
work before i did youtube
as a street salesman of hot dogs so
today we're making the king
of all hot dog street food the house
bishop
this is not only swedish it is local
for my hometown gothenburg if you go to
gothenburg
you get a flipping hub special house
bizarre means half special and i
i don't understand why it's a it's a hot
dog with mashed potatoes on it
it's called half special i i don't ask
okay just don't act
i'm too tall guys this is an issue but
here are the recipes
you need taters
irish noises we must be quick hot dog
bread
uh butter it doesn't have to be wet of
course
ah five second rule it's all good
it's all good the tater is fine you can
relax
of course you gotta get the hot dogs and
some salt and pepper
ready to flip and do this smash like
subscribe for more cooking videos
why am i so cold first we peel the
potatoes
okay we should probably boil the water
i'll do that now just in case you're
following the recipe you
uh you boil the water if you don't know
how to boil water i got bad news for you
neither do i help me i remember in a
cooking class in sweden for some reason
our
cooking teacher was very weird about the
right amount of water for the potatoes
because if you use too much you lose
some of the nutrition but obviously
and you're not supposed to put the
potatoes i'm sure someone's gonna say
i'm wrong
but i don't care all right in case my
home school teacher is watching you're
supposed to
put the potatoes after the potato boils
okay
yeah but then if you can't use too much
water
and the water evaporates you don't know
how much water you're supposed to get
and i remember when we did the test me
and my friend
the moment we realized that we nailed
the amount of water we were like
yeah yeah we got the right amount of
water for the potatoes
like that matters at all for the cooking
that's a fun story from childhood yes
don't forget to salt the water
i don't know how much to put while the
water
boil up we peel potato okay make sure
you wash your potatoes
like a caressing a newborn child that's
how you want to do it
and then this is crazy you peel the
potato
i noticed putting like a paper towel
underneath is such a good life hack
usually in sweden we just peel the
potatoes in the sink and then we clean
it oh i missed cutting
and this is gross you do this and once
you peel bing bang boom
it's epic okay side epic
time lapse of me peeling potato
the potatoes are peeled yeah don't have
to touch
anything god damn i keep dropping now
actually i think
i almost forgot since we were gonna make
them into mash
anyway you can just cut them so they
boil quicker
yeah jacksepticeye is crying right now
fun fact potatoes is the only
invention out of ireland congrats
ireland you did something
how does that feel but you don't have an
a b separator
can the water boil already jesus edgar
hungary here
house bicycle parish can i get a house
for shower please
praise i bring good boy
[Music]
we usually feed our pugs at lunch and
maya looks absolutely
depressed and destroyed red versus
you hear that yeah boiling time
yeah splish yeah
we let it boil 20 minutes something like
that
a little less i put too much water look
at that i'm a disgrace
i'm sorry homeschool teacher sweden i
don't remember your name okay
look at that perfect amount of water
just kidding but you thought i messed
that up didn't you
now confession time i was never actually
allowed to make
the mashed potatoes when i when it was
my job because
probably wasn't very good at it but this
is my redemption
this will be the best goddamn potatoes
every swedish person is gonna cry
looking at him because they're so
beautiful not because they're bad
just super clear okay 20 minutes see in
20 minutes
all right says here filming say hi
hi in sweden we have like this uh
like a stick to poke the potatoes with
do you have that
like a stick you poke the potatoes you
poke them in
you pull it out if the potato goes out
it's all good
you're spunk i can give you stick
no we use a fork now mom and dad don't
look at me oh god these are weight ready
i forgot that i cut them it's fine you
cannot overcook potatoes
that's impossible because you're gonna
mash anyway
yeah i'm probably right yeah yeah i
probably i did it right
i did it right oh god that's fine uh you
take a potato
and i'm not in a rush to do it at all
okay and then you grab the caster
lock and then you pour it in yeah
yeah buy water didn't like you anyway
you see the technique i have in this
that's swedish stuff
i'm burning my fingers it went through
the gloves
screwing your vitamins okay bing bang
bong
potatoes are getting along
yeah you see that
now the best part we don't have a
spatula but we have a potato
masher
what we're coming yeah
i'll match you and sit there good good
yeah what are you gonna do huh what you
gonna do huh you got nothing
you got nothing you pee inside
you get mashed what was i doing mesh
yes yes
[Music]
screw your potatoes
look at that and you're supposed to add
milk butter and salt
and pepper yeah
that looks good yeah
i don't know how much milk you put but i
don't see how you can fail in making
mashed potatoes
can you they're mashed potatoes they're
going to be mashed potatoes
without yeah those we'll start with that
yeah i keep saying yeah i don't know
what i'm doing
yeah i think we need more
nice and creamy tears that looks creamy
look at that add a little click about a
boob
[Music]
squeeze stuff yeah make sure it's
properly mixed
i think it's too much milk it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
what matter is that you have a smile on
your face
think about all the enemies you're
destroying
cocoa melon boom bam
this is what happens if you challenge me
oh we broke
no i can fix it
what god damn it
yeah fix that
okay yeah
would you eat that let me try it
with salt can i taste it
they probably put way more butter in
like street food
it's really salty really but it doesn't
taste good
olive oil no we're not italian
we use butter in this household put
olive oil one snack you want to put
nutella in it
huh
that's better okay when in doubt
add more fat to it okay
now we make you're supposed to grill the
hot dogs
do you prefer boiler grill ew
definitely real you oil girls like it
boiled
i was nice to add yes i make a general
assumption
what did i use we do people actually
boil yeah we boil them
you want a ball you want to grill that's
the thing they always ask i always ask
okay you want house for your boiled or
grilled
krill yeah coming right up
the thing is like my
we don't have a spatula ah my uh
my boss didn't want to waste because he
wanted us to pre-cook
all the food but he didn't want to waste
it in case like
not everything goes during the day so he
would tell me
to microwave the hot dog i think i said
this before
because it's so disgusting never order
boil hotdog
because what we do is put it in the
microwave and then we would dip it in
hot water
so it seems like it's so disgusting
i can't believe i did that i never
understand who wants to boil either
shane you like boiled hot dog shame
i mean we spit in kitchen
or kitchen spit like you oh yeah uh side
edit pan noises
yeah i don't really see how you can mess
this up if i mess this up i'm done with
the curry
[Music]
are they always wobbly they're tofu
don't tell them
it's not soy it's pure protein
it's made by intestines and
brains all that good stuff that you want
from hot dog
no no tofu not in my kitchen
soy cream yeah you just play around with
the hot dogs until they look good
that this would dip this takes me back
man
back to sweden being depressed
hating my life yeah making hot dogs
making making hot dogs
[Music]
why did i not sing that license we can
prepare the
ring what are you doing
no oh i had it in my beard i was spam
thank you so much so i told myself that
we have to put mustard on there
so i bought your stuff but you gave this
face i'm like
yeah why what is your problem in mustard
it's spicy yeah it's spicy
yeah you probably need that it's good
though
kitchen if i have to pay then i guess
you cannot eat it without okay in sweden
you get the option you want mustard or
ketchup all right ketchup
you don't i don't want it but i will
take it you're a sociopath
all right next up well you want a towel
on your
hot dog that might be good i might
experiment
we having to tell you yep it was a joke
i'm not going to do something crazy
person
how far are you willing to go i feel
stronger just by looking at it
so much protein have you ever heard of
putting a mashed potato
the legend will be revealed
oh they're screaming in pain
damn i like that i like to imagine that
they're in pain
they're suffering do you not warm the
bread no
hell no
the bread was nice quick
the pan is a little small i can't shake
them anymore
stop screaming you're gonna die anyway
it feels a bit weird
putting this on a plate like you're
supposed to eat it from your hand
okay hop dog ready how do i get it
oh god it's breaking that's actually a
good size yeah i usually split them in
half
and add two in one intentional yeah
okay you get the mesh
yeah that's a lot is it
you want you want a lot of mesh on it
all right add the mustard
like this you're getting a good shine
yeah oh yeah yeah i got it on my fingers
yeah there we have it a half special
very good i put it here that would be
mine
and then i'll prepare yours how many do
you want
i don't know one two three
thank you i like how it's like carb
carb yeah double the carb that's healthy
right you always tell me off
whenever i cook for making like even a
tiny little splash look at you
having everything out excuse me yeah
exposed excuse me you're exposing me
yeah you're exposing me martial
yeah what are you gonna do look at that
[Music]
you want this again there you go
that looks great
look at this you also got here the mine
how does that feel
you can't you might say it up now so i
mean
technically the mash is supposed to be
twice as much at least and you're
supposed to eat it in your hand and then
you need to match first
um that walkthrough
damn that's good the ketchup the
cinnamon
[Music]
i still got it let's try it all together
damn sweetie oh i forgot to mention it's
tradition to have it with chocolate milk
as well
so there you have it
it goes surprisingly well together you
were judging me so hard
having milk with this huh who was wrong
i remember when i was a kid i thought it
was so funny that you can half swallow
the potato
the mashed potato and then you get a
funny voice oh
yeah don't do that i want the marxian
input that she's good
[Music]
what's the review um yeah try this out
post it on the reddit i want to see your
versions
of motherflipping authentic swedish
swedish in swedish
that's it take care all right
time to feed the puggies
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten what creatures
fart spells and poop troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
remember it has a very big tv
pre-order promotion i mean